hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar utilizing
the gibco cts
radio system a versatile closed
manufacturing
system for cell and gene therapy
development
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labruth and brought to you
by gibco
by thermo fisher scientific we encourage
you to participate today
by submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply simply type them into
the ask a question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or
hearing the presentation i'd like to now
welcome our speakers
marianne santos cell and gene therapy
senior business development
development manager at thermo fisher
scientific
emily benz process development engineer
at viasight and eric debosky
biomedical engineering master's student
at cal poly
san luis obispo our speakers will now
begin their presentations
okay
thank you so much and and i would like
to welcome you again to this webinar and
thank you for taking the time to get to
know more
about our gibko rotia counterflow
centrifugation system
and before i get into the advantages of
the rotia
i just want to say the four main pillars
that thermo fisher can support you in
your cell in
gene therapy activities so first and
foremost is quality and logistics
of course we take this very seriously
because we know that failure to
manufacture
equals failure to treat and a lot of
patients are
are relying on both you and i to to
transform their lives so
three things management of supply chain
and logistics make sure
that you have quality of supply make
sure you have continuity and assurance
of supply
also we have redundancy gmp
manufacturing again
we want sure that you manufacture your
therapies patients
and along with that of course is to i'm
sorry i'm going to
click off my camera here uh but also
along with that
is advanced analytical tools so that you
know if your therapies are safe
uh second is speed to market and
innovation we want your therapies to get
to the patients but without
losing that quality regulatory very
important
that we support you on the compliance
documentation
all of those things because as you know
if you don't
comply with these regulatory
requirements the fda or the regulatory
agencies
will not let you get those therapies to
the patient so we also help you with
clinical trials risk management
again uh fourth and this is
the cost and to me this is a very near
and dear to my heart
i come from an immigrant family so i
don't come from a rich family so
when i decided to become a scientist i
wanted to impact the world
and if we can't make these technologies
affordable
and accessible to everyone that's just
going to be a travesty
so so we want to work with you so that
we can lower the cost
of goods and in order to do that we have
to come up with scalable
closed automated and modular systems
like the gibco rotia system so why
do you need it to be closed it's because
you are lower those costs if you have a
closed manufacturing process
this uh you know image right here uh the
first one that's open in manual
processing that gives me heartburn and
heartache
because you don't want that look at how
many machines you need
uh and then the second one is closed and
automated yes but it's
integrated incubation so the machine
itself will tie up your entire
manufacturing process
and the third right here is our vision
and the way we've designed and
engineered
our systems and our manufacturing
process
it's closed and automated with
centralized incubation
so you see here the manufacturing
footprint it's smaller
and then i want you to to check this
right here these are processing system
processing systems
that you will need for a typical car t
therapy
2000 patients per year when you get to
commercialization
and for the integrated incubation you'll
need seven eight of these machines
but for closing automated with
centralized incubation you only need
seven
so can you imagine how much cost you're
already going to save
with uh just this closed and automated
with centralized incubation process
and how do you do that and it's through
a system like
the gibco rotia system so four main
advantages
is a low output volume this is very
important because for example you want
to do electroporation
you don't want to elect operate you know
a large volume because then that you'll
need more engineering reagents right
you'll need more cas9
you'll need more uh uh you know guide
rna so
you can go with the rotia you can go
from let's say a liter of cell culture
volume
to five mils so you can go as little as
five mils with the rotia
process flexibility that means you could
do a lot of
activities and a lot of applications
with the rotia
without without harming
your your cell yields and the viability
i am a cell biologist myself
and i call myself cell culture a cell
culturist and a cell mommy
i don't like it when i lose my cells and
i don't like it when they're not happy
so
with a rotia it's so so gentle on the
cells so you have high cell recovery and
two you have
a high viability you maintain the the
happiness of the cells
and last but not least you with this one
machine you can go from research
through process development and all the
way through patient reality or
commercial
manufacturing
all right so what do you get when you uh
purchase the
the rotia system so first is you get
this compact instrument
i'm a very small person i'm not even
five feet tall
i have very short arms i can hug the
rotia that's how compact it is
so uh the footprint again is very
important
a single use kit uh here you go here is
the
consumables kit one two three four five
six seven input and output ports
eighth port right here that's what we
call the h port or the harvest port
and then you'll get two pieces of
software the graphic user interface you
can hear me call it
gui and also the protocol writing
software
and uh you'll get a laptop with a rotea
and that's going to connect to the
retail tell the retail what to do
now the protocol writing software you
don't need to
to write it using their laptop that
connects to the rotia
does not have a software license so you
can put in any laptop that you want
and then put your protocol in a thumb
drive and then upload it when you're
ready to run the rotia
also i want to make sure that you know
that the gui or the graphic user
interface is so user friendly so
please don't be afraid of it plus also
we're going to train you
and we'll support you from the beginning
all the way to the end
which means it's continuous because
hopefully you'll use the rotia
forever so uh
next i want to show you here the process
flexibility of
of the rotia so you can use it here this
is a typical cell therapy processing
from
vein to vein and you could use it to saw
quite preserved material and exchange it
to media or you can do the reverse
you can wash and concentrate from uh
from the actual cell culture volume that
you have there and then
put it into higher preservation media so
uh also
like i said earlier you can also use the
rotia to wash and concentrate into an
electroporation buffer
to get ready for your genome engineering
we have protocols for each of these
so you're not going to have to reinvent
the wheel and like i said we will
support you
every step of the way
how does the wordtaia work if you don't
know about counterflow centrifugation
it's just
how it sounds two forces at work here
flow rate
this way g-force this way those are the
two
forces that are at play here and that
the cells will feel
but the way the rotia is engineered the
coriolis effect
is the pressure or the the forces that
how you feel how the cells feel these
two forces
full rate and g-force but because of the
small
chamber it does not feel that coriolis
effect too much
and that's why it is very very gentle on
cells
so the cells go in this way i call this
the straw my engineers hate it when i
call this raw but i'm a biologist that's
how it looks to me
so uh the cells go in and
when you control the g-force and the
flow rate or the mills per minute
you will dictate to the machine what you
would like
to to stay what cells you would like to
stay in the chamber and that is what we
call the fluidized bed
so the fluidized bed or the cells it's
kind of like a tornado it's just going
around and around
right there right here and it's never a
pellet
so with counter flow centrifugation the
cells are never pelleted like i said
it's just like a tornado
so with your control so you control this
smells permanent and g-force you will
know what cells you want
fluidize and what cells you would like a
luteriated
so what i mean by alluterations are the
cells that are not in equilibrium with
the flow rate and the g-force
will allu trade out or exit out of the
chamber leaving the cells that you want
in the cfc chamber that's what we call a
luteriation
so for example red blood cells platelets
right they're smaller
than your lymphocytes and your monocytes
so you can elutrate out
the smaller cells or later on i'll show
you some other applications
where you can use the rotia to to
separate out other cell types
so here you see the cells that you don't
want i'll do trading out
because you're controlling the flow rate
and also the g-force
control is with you
so here again it shows you uh you load
the cells
here we go you trade out the cells that
you don't want
and you wash because it's never pelleted
you don't have to resuspend
right you don't have to go up and down
or anything like that the cells will be
washed
very very efficiently in the rotia
itself and then you exchange
to whatever buffer you want whether it's
electrication buffer quiet preservation
anything that you want now you do have
to be very careful that the density of
the wash media
is not very different from the the
density of the media that your cells are
in or else you will disrupt
that fluidized bed so again we will
train you
there are protocols that go around that
and
uh so we will help you as you're using
the the rotia and then you can
concentrate the cells
so get in the protocol you will tell the
rotia i want it to be concentrated into
five
ten twenty however you want again total
control with you guys
so four four main advantages again
process flexibility you can do a lot
with the rotia happy happy cells
third low output volumes and fourth you
can use it from research
all the way through commercial
manufacturing this is one of my favorite
slides here
i want to tell you that it's open
architecture for process development and
then you can lock it down
for for gmp manufacturing i i like the
fact that it's open architecture
because i came from pd as as well back
in
past life and and we will not charge you
every time you want to change your
protocol
that is your scientific creativity at
work here so we want to harness that not
hinder it
so we're not going to charge you for
that so it is open architecture and then
of course it's very important
when you get to gmp that you lock it
down
so that is why you can lock down the
rotaia protocols once you
are at gmp
so rotia is a gmp will it satisfy your
gmp requirements absolutely
uh here's the instrument it's
manufactured under iso one three four
eight five it is cts which means cell
therapy system
when you see within thermal fissure the
cts brand you could breathe this sigh of
relief because we take the
the regulatory burden we minimize that
from you we take that from you
so that you can focus on the
technologies that you want to develop
and get those therapies
to patients so it is cts the instrument
is ctf the single-use kit
is also manufactured under iso 13485
and in an iso 7 grade clean room
software itself we have an additional
software an sae system that you can
purchase to make it 21 cfr
part 11 compliant
all right so versatile right i said many
different applications i'm not going to
read you this slide just remember swiss
army knife
of cell therapy that is what the rotate
is you can do a lot
with it second favorite slide here
because i love presenting data so you
can see here high cell recovery and
viability over 95 percent
and then we concentrated also t cells
200 times
with 97 recovery and you could see the
viability here still
really great with greater than 90
recovery and here you could see
high pvmc recovery from a leukopak
and only just a few rbc contamination
here
because there's still overlap of course
with red blood cells and pbmcs but you
could see high recovery here then you
could go on to your
next step in the isolation of your the
cells that you want
this is how it looks like uh these are
five billion t cells in the chamber so
you gotta watch out
of course uh so it's continuous flow
rate there's no
maximum volume really that you can
process it's just you gotta watch
uh the cells that are in the chamber
itself so you can harvest this out
uh in loops so you can in one protocol
you can just
do multiple harvests and here's phycol
versus
rotia so you can see the growth of the t
cells did not get affected
and also markers here you could see fico
versus rotia there's no difference so we
did not affect the phenotype
here's before cd8 as well before and
after rotation processing you can see
that we did not change those ratios
and also we did not affect the phenotype
because the verteia is very very gentle
here again uh fico versus uh rotia
now if i call open manual very
cumbersome two hours with the rotates
you press that button and you're good
uh less than 30 minutes to process the
lucopaca this is i believe is a quarter
luca pack
many different cell types this is a
natural killer cells the wash and
concentrate you could see the recovery
is here
and the viabilities and no changing of
cd16 and cd56 phenotype the markers
so you could process natural killer
cells here you can clarify super names
when you're
looking at lentivirus purification these
are 293 cells
viral transduction right here you did
not change it you did not affect it it's
because the rotate
again is very gentle on the 293 cells
which you don't need anyway you could
just
uh uh harvest the supernate and here are
ipsc's uh
processing uh which my of my
friends here from viasight will talk
about
and you could see the process
development that we've done here when we
were processing
ipscs so
uh last but not least here i want to
just say that we also are are developing
products so that it will connect to the
chair just like uh
you know these uh pbs uh and uh aim five
in bpcs already so these uh two beings
right here will connect to the retailer
c-flex
and pvc because the rotia's the
single-use kits are pvcs
so uh we are constantly trying to make
sure that you are
the the reagents that you need will be
connected to the retail
because ultimately ultimately what you
want is a closed
manufacturing process uh right here is
what we are currently doing
and also for our partners as well as to
connect the entire cell therapy
process completely closed in the modular
system
integrated but modular under the control
of the bioprocessing software
like the true bio delta v so please let
me know if you are or your
your business development managers if
you're interested in partnering with us
to make your processes completely closed
and with that i thank you for your
attention
thanks marianne for the great
introduction um eric and i will now
dive into biocites development of the
rotia for
automated processing of our stem cell
aggregates
and so viacite is a regenerative
medicine company developing stem
cell-derived cell therapies that hold
the promise of a functional cure for
patients with type 1 diabetes
our cell therapy is a combination
product and so it's comprised
of stem cell derived insulin producing
cells encapsulated in
a immunoprotective device and so after
implant the device becomes vascularized
to allow for nutrient and small molecule
transfer across the membrane
and so our insulin-producing cells can
then respond to blood glucose levels
as you can see by the graph here we have
performed preclinical
studies that show successful control of
blood glucose levels
the x-axis is time in days and the
y-axis
is showing blood glucose levels the
green line is
a non-diabetic mouse and so you can see
stable
levels and then the blue line is a
diabetic mouse where you can see
extremely large fluctuations
however after implant
and over time as our cells mature in
vivo
they begin to respond to glucose levels
and can effectively
control them similar to that observed in
the
non-diabetic mouse and so the overall
goal is
to provide long-term insulin
independency to
diabetic patients
so our production process is occurs over
about
30 days initially we saw human embryonic
stem cells
and expand those in flasks and cell
stacks over a period of
15 days and to generate enough cell
product
to then aggregate and perform a
directed differentiation down the
pancreatic progenitor
lineage upon the final day of
differentiation
our pancreatic endoderm cells or pecca1
are frozen down
for long-term storage and then upon need
they are thawed
and seeded into one of our device
configurations
where that device is then implanted into
our patients
worldwide there is an increasing
incidence of type 1 diabetes
so to support the millions of diabetic
patients we would require a commercial
scale production of our cell
manufacturing process
and so to meet this demand one option
would be to scale out our process
scaling out involves multiplying the
number of batches and so
in our case that would lead to hundreds
of roller bottles
and as you can assume that becomes
unrealistic very quickly as this leads
to high septic risk
a large production footprint and higher
costs
therefore it's important to develop a
scale up model
where we increase batch size to support
large-scale
production
and so scaling up a cell therapy
requires multiple considerations a few
of them being process comparability so
ensuring that
across batches and across scales
you're producing the same product you're
maintaining
product integrity um additionally it's
important to establish a great
relationship with your vendors and even
consider multiple
vendors for various consumables and
reagents
and then additionally being aware of the
facility capacity needs
and whether you perform your production
process
in-house or in collaboration with a cmo
however the focus of today's
presentation is really
identifying scale-up technologies that
meet the process requirements
so for our process we have decided to
transition to suspension by reactor
systems because they're closed
controlled and scalable which allows for
a robust
commercial production process and so in
conjunction with the bioreactor we
require
a cell separation system to perform
closed media exchanges and harvesting
processes
which leads us to the rotia and so eric
will be discussing how we've
incorporated the rotia system
as a suitable technology that meets our
needs
thanks emily so first some details on
the aggregates and the drug substance
that we are using
uh that we do that we're processing with
the rotia
vinesite drug cell drug substance or
pec-01
consists of pancreatic progenitor
aggregates these aggregates are
pretty dense they're comprised of
multiple cell populations at different
phases
of differentiation there's also
extracellular matrix
uh in each aggregate usually we see
aggregates between
200 and 400 microns in diameter
the aggregates typically grow in size as
we move along the differentiation
process
so like emily mentioned we want to use
the rotata system
as part of our aggregate production
process
and the rotate system is good for this
application because it addresses several
of our requirements for aggregate
processing
specifically it allows us to accomplish
media exchange
passage and harvest of aggregates and
cells
while maintaining a closed environment
it's also an efficient
processing regime the entire process
should take less than an hour in total
there's no effect to aggregate viability
morphology or characterization after
processing
cortea is also a gentle processor and
its single use
allows us to maintain a closed
environment and minimize aseptic risk
it also allows the isolation of a
specific cell population so we can
separate the aggregates
from non-aggregates and also from any
dead or single cells that we don't want
in our final harvest
population and then finally as emily
mentioned it is a scalable technology
meaning that as we scale up our
production process the rotate will be
able to be scaled with us
so a brief overview of the pec 01 scale
up development workflow
and where the rotator fits into that
workflow
to start our production process we
expand
human embryonic stem cells from thaw
into 2d adherent culture on flasks
move from flask to cell stacks and then
we aggregate
our cells in preparation for
differentiation into the final
cell cell product this differentiation
process
occurs in suspension bioreactors and
this is where we see the rotator being
integrated into our process
allowing us to have a closed process
media exchange and harvest
and also efficient and streamlined
processing to
process our aggregates and remove any
non-aggregate debris
after this part of the process we then
move to crowd preservation and post dog
culture
finishes out the production
of our cell therapy product
so in order to integrate the rotate into
our process
we first had to perform some initial
testing
with our aggregates just to see what
parameters would be good to maintain
accurate morphology integrity and
viability as they were processed
and the way we did this was with just a
very basic
initial testing setup using a couple of
bottle assemblies i'm going to walk you
through here
and this allowed us to see what flow
rates and what centrifuge speeds
were best suited for maintaining
aggregate morphology integrity and
viability
so first we drew aggregate cells in
through an input bottle
this would be representative of our
suspension bioreactor
the cells were drawn into the rotate
counter flow centrifugation cone
and we tried to form bends at various
flow rates and centrifuge speeds
the spent media from the input i sent to
the waste
along with any non-aggregate cell debris
that was removed from the fluidized bed
by the
the aggregates uh still in this
counterflow centrifugation cone were
then washed with fresh medium
and finally the processed and
concentrated aggregates were sent from
the rotate to a harvest bottle
where we could then confirm that the
aggregates were
still viable and still intact and this
setup allowed us
to narrow down the range of flow rates
and centuries fees that best maintain
our aggregate
properties that we were looking for
so like i mentioned there were two
process parameters that we're primarily
interested
in optimizing one is the pump flow rate
and the reason we're interested in this
parameter is because if it's too low
we have a slow processing time with the
rotateo but there may be some
improved aggregate retention conversely
if
pump flow rate is too high we get faster
processing
but we might have lower viability of
retention of our aggregates
on the flip side when we're optimizing
centrifuge feed
if the centrifuge speed is too low you
won't retain any of your aggregates
they'll be alluded directly to the waste
conversely there if your centrifuge feed
is too high
you're going to have low aggregate
viability and you might also retain some
of the debris that you don't want in
your final product
so these were the two primary parameters
that we were interested in optimizing
using the test setup that we just saw
it is worth mentioning there are several
other parameters that may affect the
process inputs or outputs
however these were assumed constant for
testing for practical reasons
some of these include the media density
and viscosity the density of the
aggregates themselves
the diameter of the aggregates and the
number of wash steps performed by the
rotate during our process
so one of the other things that we're
evaluating uh during these initial tests
was we wanted to make sure that our
process
actually formed a fluidized bed in the
counterflow centrifugation cone
and this is important because the
fluidized bed maintains the integrity of
the aggregates and also ensures that
they are correctly
retained and sent to the harvest as
opposed to being sent to the waste
and as you can see on the picture on the
left there we were able to successfully
form
a nice looking fluidized bed in the
counter flow centrifuge cone
we're also interested in evaluating the
viability of the aggregates after
processing
and this could be visually seen by any
turbidity
in the counterflow centrifuge cone
during processing
and also a post-process we would look at
the aggregates under
a light microscope as seen in the middle
picture there
and confirmed that the aggregates were
intact and then
using software to make sure that our
diameter after processing
is comparable to the diameter before
processing we would also look at the
viability before and after processing
as seen on the graph on the far right
pretest we would see aggregate viability
in the high 90
post test we would also see comparable
viability after roteo processing
another thing we're interested in for
our production process
is processing the aggregates over
multiple days or multiple media
exchanges
and this is because as emily mentioned
our production process takes several
days
so we want to be able to use the rotia
for multiple days if possible
without any negative effects on our
aggregates and
so during our testing we processed
accurates from multiple successive
days in a row and observed a minimum
loss in viability as seen on the graph
on the left here
over three days we would process the
aggregates once each day
with a divide with the rotation and we
would see minimum change
in viability after each processing of
only about three percent loss in
viability
after each test we also looked at
diameter after multiple successive
processing days
and once again saw a minimal change in
aggregate diameter as seen on the graph
on the right
in fact on day two we actually saw a
slight not
statistically sniffing about a slight
increase in aggregate diameter
suggesting that we're in fact removing
some of the non non-aggregate debris
that would have small diameters that's a
good thing we wanted to see
that debris get sent to the waste
instead of the harvest
so now that we've established the
approximate initial conditions that we
want to see
integrated into our production process
we can also look into possible future
applications
of the rotated to our cell therapy
production process
so this is our overview of our
production process
expansion differentiation preservation
of postdoc culture
we're currently looking in the middle
there to integrating the rotate to our
aggregation differentiation steps
however in the future we might be able
to look to integrating the rotate to our
expansion
steps where the rotate might have a role
in stem cell expansion
cell passaging it might also be useful
for our crowd preservation and post
thought culture steps
specifically for the crowd preservation
harvest and during our post-thought
culture
and with that some concluding remarks uh
biocite
is developing some stem cell derived
therapies to functionally cure type 1
diabetes
and in order to meet this ambitious goal
we need an ambitious scale of effort
to support our predicted cell therapy
demand the retail
provides a scalable technology that can
support closed and efficient processing
or stem cell aggregate therapy and our
preliminary results
show high aggregate viability and normal
morphology over consecutive processing
days
thank you for your attention
thank you marianne emily and eric for
your informative presentations
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
how can you process larger volumes i.e
10 liters with the rotia
that is a good question so as you scale
in batch volume uh your cell product
volume increases as well
since the maximum hold volume of the
rotia counterflow centrifugation
10 milliliters of fluidized fed the path
forward would be to process the
bioreactor solution in matches
each one comprised of a maximum volume
of maximum aggregate volume
of 10 milliliters and this can occur
multiple times depending
on your load size and additionally a
high flow kit
allows for improved flow rates to
support faster processing of these
larger batches
great thank you so much and our next
question
why choose a suspension culture method
i.e
in general what are the overall benefits
you see in suspension
culture versus 2d adherent methods for
stem cell research
yeah um so the advantage of suspension
culture over
to the adherent methods for stem cell
production becomes
really apparent as the stem cell
expansion and differentiation process
is scaled compared to 2d adherent
methods
some fall production processes utilizing
suspension culture
combine improved cell processing
characteristics such as
unlimited capacity for growth so no
surface area limitations
and then at a lower aseptic risk with
lower production costs so
reduced equipment footprint and labor
requirements
thank you emily our next question
what led to vyasite's decision in
selecting the rotia for bioreactor
processing
yeah so in addition to its ability to
maintain
aggregate viability integrity and
morphology
the rotia's counterflow centrifugation
technology
is scalable making it as suitable
as making it suitable for via site's
process as we
scale up production additionally the
rotia also
matches our requirement for repeated
batch
bioreactor media exchange versus
typical perfusion based processes on the
market
and what are the steps planned to make
it suitable for use in later phase and
commercial processes
so uh thank you for that question i'll
take this one so it's
the word the cts gibco rotea system
is designed for clinical manufacturing
so the instrument
the single-use kit they're all cgmp
grade and manufactured like i said
earlier
under iso 13485 so the official
regulatory message
for the instrument and the single-use
kits
it's for research use or manufacturing
of cell
gene or tissue based products and
also like i mentioned earlier the rotia
software has operator
and administrator modes for
manufacturing
and then the retail also has a 21 cfr
part 11 compliance software solution
that will be available in the third
quarter of this year
so thank you thank you marianne
our next question is the entire product
contact flow path for the cts retia
single use
okay question uh so the entire fluid
path for the
rotia system um single use kit was
evaluated
for regulatory requirements so that
includes biocompatibility
endotoxins extractables and a lot more
you can see it in rcoa
and all the regulatory testing results
are available with the
rotia systems regulatory support file or
the rsf
all right thanks again marianne our next
question can single-use kits be reused
for testing purposes
yes you can reuse single-use kits for
testing purposes
but it is important to watch the
integrity of a pump tubing and to clean
out the tubing and counterflow
centrifuge cone after each use to remove
any debris or any adhered aggregates or
cells
however these kits are advertised as
single use so the official
recommendation
for use with the final process is not to
reuse the single use case
thank you eric and our next question
what are the greatest challenges to
rotate out optimization for aggregate
processing
good question the stencil aggregates
that we work with they require
gentle handling because they can be
quite fragile
it's necessary to maintain aggregate
integrity during the processing
because this is a critical part of their
functionality in the final product
so modifying the rotia process
parameters to adequately collect
wash refeed the aggregates from the
bioreactors it took some fine-tuning to
do
but assistance from thermofisher and
working through
the through the parameters to optimize
the shear forces
was was an interesting process however
we have achieved successful cultures
utilizing this system
thanks again eric our next question here
is
can you further detail other potential
areas of via site cell process for the
rotia could add value
sure so as we discussed in the
presentation biosite has adapted the
rotia to our stem cell aggregate
differentiation process
however we see a multiple multitude of
other areas where the retail could offer
support
one of those includes the final harvest
for crop preservation
when we generate our drug substance we
require an intermediate freezing step
for long-term storage and the rotate
could benefit this process by
concentrating
washing and collecting the final product
in choir preservation media
thank you our next question when
adapting your feeding and harvesting
processes to the rotia
did you run into any issues if the
aggregate solution is not uniform
i.e heterogeneous mix of smaller to
larger aggregates
that is a great question uh because our
aggregates
do tend to range inside we cop size we
commonly see aggregate solutions
that have sent several standard
deviations worth of size approximately
50
there but since the aggregates are so
much larger than the single cells we
want to remove
from the solution we haven't had a whole
lot of issues separating the two
thanks again eric our next question is
how does the cts rotia compare to the
prodigy from miltoni
okay i'll take that one thanks i i get
this a lot
so i'll answer this question so the
rotate is very different from the
miltoni prodigy
on a lot of friends uh so the rotia
again
i i had my favorite slide i'm gonna quiz
you on this now my favorite slide right
you i said that it's an
open architecture so it's an open
platform that it's reagent
agnostic and bead agnostic so you can
use
your whatever reagents that you would
like uh
like i said it's it's open it's you are
under you have the control
whenever you use the rotia so and also
i showed you the vision that we have so
you can combine it with
you know offline incubator scale that's
better for manufacturing
because it doesn't have an integrated
incubator
like the prodigy so it it allows for
modular
manufacturing
thank you thank you marianne and our
next question here is
how involved is the support for
developing a process
can you help design the program used for
ourselves
okay i'll take this one as well thank
you for for that question
so thermo fisher scientific we are very
invested in the success of
each of our rotia system customers
so we provide support throughout the
instrument buying experience
so for example a custom protocol is
developed for each rotea system demo
in order to suit your specific
application and then
lifestyle demos perform with the rotate
system
for your evaluation
also we include initial equipment and
software training
by our trained field application
scientists
and then post sale you have an entire
support system myself
the field application scientist and the
tech support teams are available
for further protocol development
assistance
so we're all here for you
thank you thank you okay marianne our
next question here is
is the system often used in combination
with cell factories eg
media exchange and also cf40
i'll take this question and and thank
you for for asking this
uh yes so so the rotate system is is
extremely it's so tremendously flexible
and it's designed to be completely
customizable
so it's been connected to incubators
bioreactors
cf-40s you know cell factories as part
of a closed
manufacturing system like that one slide
that last flight that i
i showed you that is the ultimate goal
is to have a closed
entirely closed manufacturing process so
in order to connect to cell factories
uh what we use is off-the-shelf pvc
c-flex adapters
so that's required thank you
thank you and uh our last question here
what is the approximate process time to
go from one thousand
milliliters to five milliliters
mary ann again here uh so depending on
the chosen settings again you're under
your
you have the control uh the volume
reduction processing time for one liter
down to five mils can be you know as
fast
as 20 minutes
thank you great thank you again marianne
thank you again all of you marianne
emily and eric for your time today
and for your important research we would
also like to thank
labrus and our sponsor gibco by thermo
fisher scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration this webcast
can be viewed on demand lab roots will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye